moving to the complex numbers okay um
part 1 very well done good job you're
good with binomial theorem that's not to
be that's not surprising because its
extension one when you got to part two
this was also pretty well done but the
place people drop marks was here
remember i talked about fudge i talked
about fudge if you didn't use
trigonometric identities the result is
given right so if i didn't see you using
the pythagorean identity somewhere i was
looking for one minus one minus sine
squared to be replacing all his cos
squared terms then it was clear to me
you weren't actually showing you were
kind of taking a shortcut because your
knew where you were supposed to end up
okay so you've got to use those
identities somehow to get the second
mark pie three two different ways to do
this they're both fine you can either
literally carry on from the last line of
part two you just got that result so put
in theni equals play on tab just
substituted in right and you will see
what comes out here is my substitution
line right here a lot of people went
this path five times pilot and is PI on
to and we know what sine PI on two is ok
but because this show question I really
was looking for you to do that right and
not just say I to one turn our magic I
know you know it's a 1 it says on the
paper it's a one you've got to show me
where that came from sign pile up to
alternatively you could have done the
substitution this is equally fine but a
lot of people got to this point and they
wasted time with general solution which
you don't know yet and so you ended up
in and are being very inefficient you
can just say this this is fine right one
is sign pile to like this is the reverse
of the way I didn't before right so if
you got sign of 5 theta sine of pi/2
clearly taking sides out of the picture
is one of the solution it's one of them
are you gonna need to show satisfy so
you don't need to say it's all of these
different cases they're irrelevant okay
part 4 long division or synthetic
division both fine okay um I think some
people got mucked up because either way
they went they forgot that there were
terms with zeros
as their coefficients na forgot they got
the X to the 4 term and they forgot the
x squared term and obviously that mucks
up your entire division whether you do
it synthetic or long okay so there was
one block their part 5 the easiest way
was to compare coefficients so you can
see the way I've done it right I took
this 4x squared plus KX minus 1 if I
square that I ought to end up with the
quartet component of my quinton right
and there it is right there there's the
quartic component I can pick any of the
coefficients I want it just looked like
the easiest one was these guys it makes
the cut the comparison very
straightforward okay but you could pick
it otherwise of you we've gotten that
mark moving on rhombus at the end this
was done poorly and I was kind of
surprised because this is a textbook
question it's a textbook question and it
does come up in the HSE quite often
you've been led all this way to be able
to find sine PI on 10 which is quite an
astonishing result I was looking for
this kind of thing to be able to exclude
the X minus 1 right sine PI of 10 can't
possibly be equal to what you didn't
need to reason it you just said to state
it so that you could exclude this answer
right just like in Pythagoras you
exclude a negative result because you're
looking at length right you always have
to say why though not not an essay once
you recognize okay I need to be solving
this thing the sine PI on 10 it mustn't
be a solution of this so it must come
from over here right you just launched
into the quadratic formula that's all
I've done here just make it a bit
clearer there we go here's my quadratic
formula I go ahead and solve and just
like before I must exclude a solution
okay I'm excluding this solution here
the negative one because sine PI on 10
it's in the first quadrant you coulda
said first quadrant you could have said
acute you could have said it with this
inequality language that I have done any
of those are fine so long as you
actually give me a reason for why it's
not the case now you can't just say
cause I don't want it to be right give
me a reason why I didn't have to be long
you exclude that and that's where your
arm second second mark came from last
part this actually this is probably
easier
he intended it was very similar actually
to the VA's results the summer product
of roots before I just want to point out
a lot of you got lazy at this point of
the proof and I understand I get it I
understand why you got lazy because he's
got time to write all of that um if you
didn't want to write that all out you
really need to say like you've got to
say something more than this like I know
what you mean but that couldn't mean
anything like really it's like the sum
of all alpha betas for whatever through
Norris all right if you want to say the
sum of the roots two at a time say the
sum of the roots two at a time it's a
little bit messy but at least I do what
you were talking about and when you got
this it didn't just come from the answer
that was given to you in the question
okay